pull the cat trigger i think i'm gonna  finally get a cat if you want if you  want your house to smell like [ __ ] all  the time cat's the way to go oh oh oh  look at me i'm ari  i make jokes about cats leave my cat  alone dude look at you why do you think  it's gonna smell like [ __ ] because they  [ __ ] in the house because i'm going but  i'm gonna get one of those uh  self-cleaning litter boxes with the  scent it okay you'll be the one  it's not gonna and then you'll go it  doesn't smell like [ __ ] it's like fine  then i must have smelled something  else through this and then you're gonna  get a cat you know many people's houses  smell like dog you get the dog  not dog [ __ ]  there's a dog my house smells like  puerto ricans  you don't think there's a way to have it  because they [ __ ] in the house that's  right you're googling the house smelling  like a cat by the way oh from wachtobe  the place to sell stuff that makes you  that that has a vested interest in  business-wise